SCHOOLS, AND BUSINESSES.
ARE THEY ACTUALLY EFFECTIVE,
THOUGH?
AND HOW WELL DO THEY WORK
WITHOUT MASKING?
OUR RANDI KAYE TONIGHT HAS SOME
ANSWERS.
>> 3, 2, 1.
>> Reporter: INSIDE THIS LAB AT
FLORIDA ATLANTIC UNIVERSITY, TWO
ENGINEERING PROFESSORS ARE
SIMULATING A COUGH TO SEE HOW
CORONAVIRUS DROPLETS MAY SPREAD
FROM THE WORKPLACE AND OTHER
REAL WORLD SITUATION.
THIS MANNEQUIN'S MOUTH IS FILLED
WITH WATER AND GLYCERIN.
A GREEN LASER CAPTURES THE
DROPLETS IN THE AIR.
THE PROFESSORS AREN'T SO
CONCERNED ABOUT THE BIG DROPLETS
THAT FALL TO THE GROUND.
IT'S THE SMALL IR AIR DROPLETS.
WHEN THE MANNEQUIN COUGHS, THE
SCREEN TRAPS MOST OF THE LARGER
PARTICLE SOS THE PERSON ON THE
OTHER SIDE MAY AVOID A DIRECT
HIT.
BUT THOSE SMALLER PARTICLES
STILL ESCAPE AROUND THE SIDES
AND OVER THE TOP.
>> THEY'RE NOT 100%, THE PASSAGE
OF THE DROPLET TO THE OTHER
SIDE.
BUT IT REDUCES THE NUMBER THAT
GOES THROUGH.
>> THIS PROFESSOR SAYS THE
SCREENS REDUCE THE DROPLET
CONCENTRATION BY ABOUT 80%, SO
THE VIRAL LOAD IS MUCH LOWER.
AND THE COUGH STREAM MAY NOT GO
AS FAR WITH THE SCREEN.
WHEN WE VISITED THIS LAB EARLIER
IN THE PANDEMIC TO TEST THE
POWER OF A COUGH WITHOUT A
PLEXIGLASS SCREEN, DROPLETS
TRAVELLED AS FAR AS 12 FEET WITH
NOTHING TO STOP THEM.
BUT EVEN WITH THE SCREEN,
LIGHTER AEROSOIZED DROPLETS CAN
ACCUMULATE IN THE AIR.
IT HAS TO BE A HIGH QUALITY
MASK.
WHEN WE TRIED A SIMPLE CLOTH
MASK, THIS HAPPENED.
>> 3, 2, 1.
>> Reporter: MOST OF THE
DROPLETS GOT THROUGH.
AND WHILE THE SCREENS CAN HELP
PROTECT YOU, THE PROFESSOR SAYS
TOO MANY OF THEM IN ONE ROOM CAN
BLOCK AIRFLOW AND PUT PEOPLE AT
RISK.
NOW, THIS TYPE OF SETUP
SIMULATES AN OFFICE ENVIRONMENT.
IT'S A PLEXIGLASS DESK WITH
THREE SIDES.
YOU MIGHT ALSO FIND THIS IN THE
CLASSROOM.
THE QUESTION IS, IF SOMEBODY
COUGHS, WILL IT STOP THE SPREAD?
SO, LET'S TURN OUT THE LIGHTS
AND FIND OUT.
THE THREE-SIDED SCREEN HELPS
CONTAIN A SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF
THE DROPLETS.
MOST SWIRL WITHIN.
>> SO, THE SCREEN ALSO SLOWS
DOWN THE FORCE OF THE COUGH NET.
>> YEAH, EXACTLY.
>> Reporter: STILL, HE WARNS IF
THE AIR IN THE ROOM IS FLOWING
TOWARD THE SOURCE OF THE COUGH,
THERE COULD BE A BACK DRAFT
EFFECT.
IN THAT CASE, THE VIRUS TRAPPED
BEHIND THE DESK WOULD BE PUSHED
FURTHER BACKWARD TOWARD THOSE
SEATED BEHIND THE PERSON WHO
COUGHED.
WITH THE WORKPLACE DESK SETUP,
WE TRIED A HIGH QUALITY N95 MASK
TO SEE IF IT HELPED.
PROOF A WELL-FITTED MASK IS KEY.
DROPLETS GOING